hi everybody i'm mark wahlberg welcome
to the big date as you know all of
today's players are here because they
want to hook up with a member of the
opposite sex it's going to happen they
will hook up and when they do they have
a chance to go on a really big date that
we pay for let's meet our first player
brandi stevens 23 year old elementary
education student here she
is we're gonna bring out some guys for
you to meet in a moment but brandi what
are you looking for in a guy
tall dark and somebody i can just kick
it with you say tall because of course
you're pretty tall how tall six feet
you're six feet tall with the heels in
six three well there you go three guys i
want to introduce to you to right now
let's say hello to him quickly greg
fennell he's 27 years old he's a cable
tv dispatcher craig come on out
the 21 year old salesman daryl forest
let's bring darryl out right now
[Applause]
hi daryl welcome next guy is 23 years
old he's a commercial diver and his name
is richard west come on out richard
[Applause]
all right we'll start with you greg
you're on a date with a lovely lady like
brandi how do you make her feel special
hi brandi hi how are you good
first thing i thought to myself this is
the only [ __ ] that has his leg
crossed yes that's the first thing yeah
you know he's feeling himself yeah yeah
he looks comfortable
he's just like
he's like he's like i'm over these
[ __ ] he's not just over them
he's over the host too
how are you gonna make her feel special
hey brandy
so what do you take her off for a first
date randy look at me
look at me
i'm the captain now
all right
so i'm about to steal your ship you got
that girl
right it's about to be smooth sailing
wet seas how are you doing
all right brandi relax never seen dry
seas open them legs all right brandi you
ready make her feel special by making an
eye contact with her and
this thing is over i'm going to make a
special about you know doing what i do
right now yeah and look at her face
the eye contact thing is good huh brandi
let me tell you something if a girl
looks at you and they start doing this
no it has to be quick
super quick
it's a little it's a lot of things that
depends how much lipstick and how
nervous she about her stick exactly
exactly let me clear all that [ __ ] up
yeah
don't think i don't know
of course you know go ahead you think i
don't know you know i didn't know if you
knew that i knew that she knew that i
knew of course i know that you know that
i know that you know i just wanted to
make sure that we know oh we know okay
well you know let them know okay let's
just try to extra fix yourself while
i've been settled what about you what do
you like to do on a first date to make a
girl kind of feel special well i like to
take her to like the beach or something
and sure like some night scenery you
know cheryl is something new that she
hasn't seen before exactly it doesn't
compare right there right there this
this you know i mean like you know i
mean this isn't compared to what you
mean the birdman hand rub don't worry it
doesn't compare to you know
smiling
make some eye contact eye contact what
about you richard what do you like to do
to make a lady feel special on a date
well basically give her a lot of
a lot of
communication
make her feel special you know
way you got to pick the guy you want to
get to know a little better brandi who's
it going to be
[Applause]
see you later boys
okay
if you guys are enjoying today's video
leave a like and comment all right but
it's your choice now greg you could stay
with brandi but before you make that
choice say hello to nikea turner she's
22 years old she's a communications
major
[Applause]
greg lost is cool for a sec he's like
damn
because i can tell in his head he was
doing the math real quick he's just like
how do i win without losing yes
and there's yet another lovely lady back
there she's 23 years old and she's 23
years old
under his breath like nobody cuts that
one
you ain't you went to telling us another
one a whole other girl god damn it as if
you needed any more choices nikki bascom
is back there come on now nikki
all right now you're just [ __ ] with
me but god damn y'all didn't notice what
he did
mm-hmm
the same thing for dude
but you ladies already know if a [ __ ]
looking at you like
okay
that's really good please we get our
second couple going here with daryl you
demand darryl come on
you've got nakia and nikki you know what
he looks like he looks like a bootleg
bobby valentino yeah
but i'll let you know behind the door
could be the woman of your dreams or
possibly your nightmares i don't know
daryl what are you gonna do
[Applause]
nikki come on up he chose you
it's your choice nicky you want to stay
with daryl we'll let you do that or
richard might be the guy for you you've
been sitting there across from one
another maybe something connected that i
missed by the way behind the door is an
is a guy who could be the perfect guy
for you nikki i think i'm going to take
the door you're going to take the dude
all right joe have a seat let's see
who's back there for nikki
[Applause]
like you're like oh my god this is good
hello hello
yes that's exactly what i was thinking i
was gonna say a taller version of
criminal minds
hi david
nikki i want you to meet david bailey
he's 23 years old he's a food server all
right david put your hands on those
buttons you guys might connect get a
couple right you're a couple your hot
new date invites you in for a night cap
but their apartment has a funky odor
would you a hold your nose and flop down
on the couch or b back your butt up and
call it a night
yeah cause if the apartment's funky
what else is
depends what kind of funky does it smell
like curry because some people just got
like that that that cultural smell but i
used to go to somalia houses and it
smelled like buddies and bananas yeah i
understand right but if it smell like
that if it smells like bleach and
bananas i don't want because it means
you'd be cooking with strong herbs and
spices i'm mad at that yeah it depends
what kind of smell i'm kind of mad now
if it smells like cat litter oh cause
i've been to some vicious places and
them smell like cat piss
when i hear a girl's got a cat i get
turned off not cool
and they stop and they stop they stop
smelling it at some point
it stops me they must at some point they
must because that [ __ ] is a strong
smell
it's like um ammonia that's what it is
ammonia i know what you're telling me
i'm telling you what it makes me think
of it is ammonia is exactly what's in
uh nail polish it doesn't smell like
nail polish
because i love the smell of nail polish
okay you're a weird name and i'm
allergic to cats too you're allergic to
cats yeah yeah so can you imagine when
you're hitting it behind from a girl and
you start crying and she was like what's
wrong i was like oh [ __ ]
you thought
she was i'm hitting it right she's like
what's wrong and i got tears coming and
you're like
she's like yeah spit on me daddy
oh man
i'm over here
it's so good
it's so good oh man
yeah but you know that [ __ ] must have
been good for me to risk it because i
went back
i was like listen the tears are gonna be
terrible you guys have one right answer
one more right answer you guys are a
couple but it's your choice now david
you could stay with nikki if you like
but then key is sitting right over there
she might be more the kind of girl that
you like to date i don't know and behind
the door is another lady
i think i'm gonna go for the door come
on
[Laughter]
[Music]
i guess the door gave you the door
bars
that's a good bar today you won't fire
today
you're preparing for a versus battle
what's going on have a good time bro
only fair nicki you went for the door
and dave is going to do the same see
i just want one of these [ __ ] to be
like i choose you mark um pikachu
i like you and i'm gonna have
you so we can either do this the easy
way or we can do this the hard way and
i'm gonna let you know i'm a warrior
now i'm not gonna choose no door i want
some booty
buddha
is
probably more important than water
having booty is more important than
breathing
yo that character is not even real it's
it's not real
that can't be a real character
what
trying to hold my breath
just to see how long i could go without
booty
all right you're gambling there let's
see if the gamble pays off this is your
mystery lady come on out say hello to
david
hi tamiko
while you're at your dates house you
discover a scrapbook containing
nude photos of their former flames
would you a close the book on the
relationship
or b strip off your clothes and give
them a kodak moment
[Applause]
we got a freak on our hands hey he was
going for the safe answer but on the
other hand you would just say
on page 10.
well i mean
i like you and i'm gonna have you
that's so funny
well you know
i mean no no bro it was more aggressive
it was it was i don't ha i don't have it
was teeth
and then tongue across the teeth i don't
have that power
god bless her you know to me
oh
and you you would just say on page 10.
well i mean
you don't think it's too freaky yeah no
i mean there's nothing nothing dirty at
all about the naked eye all right let's
see how you do on this one what are you
really looking for when you date someone
you guys right now a a person to share
your life with or b a person to share
your bed with what you're going to do
what do you think
i think she's going to go with the safe
answer with the a who to me girl she's
going to freak no safe answer what about
him
the opposite
all right because he's reading off the
other answer
hey man you want some wizard [ __ ] today
yes today you came prepared i'm hydrated
i could tell mommy is not playing
what you have to do is tell me if the
statement i read about your date is true
or false every time you write you give
50 towards that big date and if you get
at least four out of six right you get a
chance to come back on friday and draw
for a trip to sandals resort in jamaica
you fly there on air jamaica
[Music]
good luck
trudeau falls brandy attended college on
a full scholarship
true think that's true brandy yes i did
you do
one right let's even get some more money
going here true or false greg once
worked for an escort service yo
why do you already say true i don't know
he did
why do you think he did i don't know
he did with the first answers you did he
did
i think that's false she chuckles craig
true
hey
you saw it
real recognized what was it was it the
suit
real recognized was it the way he
carries himself he's just yeah
[Applause]
you got one right for fifty dollars some
more money going true or false brandy is
turned on by a man with a bald head all
the ball [ __ ] are watching right now
sweating
i'm going to say true really brandi
yeah yeah
actually
you know what she did she treated that
like it was a [ __ ] crystal ball
whole whole mystery mystery 100 bucks
here we go again true or false greg has
spent more than 500 dollars
on a gift for his day true or false
brandy
[Laughter]
i think false you think false yeah
greg
true
[ __ ] boy
careful
true too sexy for my love
for my love love let's see yeah
you know what he is what he had fought
he had fat stepfather a cow
you know what a stephen urkel and the
father
i think he's fat i think he's just he's
just filled up he got cheeks
true or false greg once made love for
eight hours straight
oh and you got a laugh laughs
i'm sorry i know
true
and then she says true after the chuckle
greg could it be after some ginseng tea
yes
he gonna give me five hundred dollars we
go [ __ ] for eight hours
[Laughter]
how much you want to bet this [ __ ] was
on ebay that night ginseng tea let's go
yo let me just eat a chinese cat see if
it does the same thing you know yao for
this yo
eight hours
so what's this
what did you think
it was just classical 90s show man it
took me back it took me back yeah that's
great yeah we had some crazy tv shows
back in the day crazy crazy shows but
anyways let us know what you guys think
in the comments below did you guys enjoy
today's video
i'm gonna get 500.00